welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled
how do we bring lung cancer diagnostic
biomarkers to the clinic
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
pierre macion
professor of medicine department of
medicine vanderbilt university school of
medicine
nashville tennessee dr masion attends a
pulmonary
and critical care inpatient service and
the pulmonary outpatient clinic at the
national va medical center
his research interests include genetic
and proteomic strategies
for the early detection of lung cancer
chemo preventative strategies for the
primary and reoccurrence
of lung cancer and investigation of the
role of genomic abnormalities
in lung cancer for a complete biography
on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following this presentation
please join me in welcoming dr pierre
mession i will now turn the presentation
over to him well thank you very much for
this introduction
and hello everybody it's my pleasure to
be here today to
discuss with you how we bring lung
cancer diagnostic biomarkers
to the clinic as a
disclosure the message to remember is
that
i work with many industries i typically
don't get funding from them
and therefore i remain independent from
the industries in general
but the work that i'm going to be
presenting
is funded by the national cancer
institute the department of defense
and the veterans administration so lung
cancer is a big problem as you all know
you probably all know somebody who have
suffered from that disease who may have
died from it who are currently
struggling with it
it's a very important killer it's a
number one cancer killer in the us
and in the world and if you look at all
diseases that are leading to
a death the respiratory death
corresponds to about 50 of all deaths
among those
lung cancer is the biggest culprit 38
of all people dying of respiratory
diseases are dying of lung cancer
so when you think about the natural
history of lung cancer
it's not perfectly known but what we
know is people
eventually develop a risk over a long
period of time
they may start smoking at the age of 10
or 15
get on with their lives and most of them
are diagnosed at around the age
of 70. at that time only
25 percent would benefit from a cure
so our job is to try to diagnose the
disease early why are we interested in
that
is because when when you diagnose it
early
you have a better chance of surviving
it's true for most diseases it's just
common sense
detect the nodule early on and it should
be able to operate on it
and offer a patient a cure earlier than
at the typical time of diagnose when
only
25 of them will survive
if we diagnose it very early on 80 or 85
percent of them could survive the
disease
so there's a great impetus to develop
strategies for early detection
so why is it important particularly
important in tennessee is because we are
suffering from
an endemic uh area of lung cancer you
see on this map whatever is brown and
dark brown corresponds to the center of
this endemic area
the percentage and actually the
prevalence of lung cancer
in this south east part of the country
is about 40 percent higher than in the
rest of the country
and it maps pretty well with the
intensity of
smoking which makes sense because
smoking is the number one cause of
cancer-related mortality
so we have to do something about this
disease and if you don't know about
yet there is a screening strategy
for early detection of lung cancer
and this is lung cancer ct screening
there are two studies represented on
this slide on the left hand side
the results from the national lung
screening trial that demonstrates that
not only
the number of cancers that we diagnose
in the lung cancer screening are greater
but more importantly the death rate
associated with lung cancer screening is
lower meaning that we are saving lives
in fact we save 20 percent
decrease in relative debt from lung
cancer
with low dose chest ct and these results
were
very much mirrored by another study
done in europe in the netherlands and in
belgium
where they found that lung cancer
incidence was also increasing with
screening but that the death rate was
lower
actually their death rate from lung
cancer
with the lung cancer screening strategy
was even
better than what we found in the us they
didn't find a
20 percent relative decrease in
mortality
but up to 35 percent
so that brought the entire world to be
excited about lung cancer screening
and try to implement this strategy one
of the biggest problem is that
this strategy is still
at the beginning you would expect that
high-risk individual would undergo lung
cancer screening
but about only 10 of them are following
that strategy at the moment
it took very long time for mammography
to be obtained by most women
or colonoscopy to be successful and we
hope that
we can fast and and you know accelerate
the implementation of lung cancer
screening because
it saves lives if i show you this
chest ct you recognize the right lung
here the left lung on the right hand
side and you see the nodule on the right
upper lobe
that nodule is dense speculated about
one and a half to two centimeter
diameter it's a lung cancer
that's an estimate it's a guess it's a
probability that this is likely to be a
lung cancer
and i can tell you that because i see
that there's a culprit on the chest ct
the culprit is outside the chest you see
here there's a lighter in this patient
pocket
and a pack of cigarettes so now we're
licking causes and diseases
but this is anecdotal but this slide is
to tell you that lung cancer detection
can be complicated and i told you that
it's related to
uh the fact that chest city alone does
not
always give you the answer and here's
why
because not only lung cancer is very
prevalent in the southeast
but it's also true that this region of
the country
is also the area where the highest
concentration of histoplasmosis
is encountered and this fungal disease
is an infectious disease
can look and appear on justice d
just like this one so it's a big
compounder
it's a big struggle in the southeast
region of the united states
so now we think okay we can use chess ct
and um is it the panacea
for lung cancer screening and we're
going to save most
lives i told you we don't save
everybody's life with low dose chest ct
this slide gives you a little idea of
what proportion we are really saving
if you're thinking about all people
dying of lung cancer
in 2020 we have about 160
000 dying of this disease
if you were to uh screen
according to the national lung screening
trial
criteria for screening meaning that your
55 years of
age and less than 75 and if you have
smoke for 30 years at least a pack a day
and you haven't quit more than 15 years
ago
we could eventually save 40 to
7 000 lives out of this 160 thousand
but in fact we are not as good as that
because
if we had to implement lucas screening
in that population
we would effectively
we could save up to 12 000 lives
and 12 000 lives is only about
8 of the entire population dying of
lung cancer so we have a long way to go
but now we have at least a strategy
for early detection of lung cancer and
yet we have to go a lot
better than just lung cancer screening
with the
current guidelines there's a big effort
currently to actually expand
the population we may screen and we hope
to save many more lives this way
so what is the problem the problem is
when you screen for lung cancer
and i want to come up with a strategy to
detect these
nodules we have it by chest ct this is a
nodule that looks very suspicious
now not all lung nodules are cancerous
and we want to find a biomarker strategy
or some
type of imaging strategy to
tell us in a non-invasive way which of
these nodules is going to be malignant
nodules is a big problem you see this
1.6 million nodules
in the united states diagnosed every
year
very small number are going to be
cancers and yet many of them undergo
surgery
the nodules that we worried about are
those that are six to thirty millimeter
diameter that are non-calcified
and we can bring them into different
risk groups if you have a tiny nodule
that's really smooth it's gonna be low
risk
less than five percent if you have a big
nodule like this
one speculative dense and
showing characteristics of high risk
your probability of cancer is very high
the difficult zone is the intermediate
zone
and that's the area that we are trying
to
improve our diagnostic in a non-invasive
way
we hope that detailed imaging can help
us with this
and we hope that eventually biomarkers
will come to the rescue
so this lung cancer nodule is a big
problem
it's um 28 billion dollars a year
and it's about the same cost of what
osteoporosis management and treatment
represents in the u.s so it's a big
healthcare burden
so how do we eventually make progress
well we have big problems because
nodules are not all the same you see
this small nodule in the left lower lobe
here
was present in 2005 and this nigel
remained
stable over six years and never changed
this is most likely a lung cancer but a
rather indolent cancer
now some of these cancer are not so
indolent
and if you look at this slide here this
nodule diagnosed in 2005
start growing slowly over time and
finally in 2013 benefit the patient had
a pet scan done he was
active uh very hot on pet
and the patient underwent a resection of
that left upper lobe
and what was found is a tumor an
adenocarcinoma
well the same patient actually over time
start developing another nodule
you can't even see nothing here but look
at here there's something
coming up over time this nigel was
growing the question was
is it the same disease or a different
disease the same cell that went to a
different lobe of the lung
it happened to be a different tumor on
the same patient
also a lung adenocarcinoma so the
message here is that although
lung nodules come in different forms
some can
remain in the land and some can become
aggressive and it's difficult to
identify them
the last nodule that i showed you that
was a cancer was not that active
so imaging is not the answer to
everything
so what's the biggest challenge the
challenge
is that we have a large portion of
people with intermediate risk for lung
cancer the nodule we don't really know
what to do with
and we want to reduce that group because
this is the group where we make
most of the mistakes and what we are
proposing here is that we basically
bring
some type of bowel marker to the rescue
we're gonna
we're gonna test all these individual in
yellow
and ask whether a biomarker can change
their group
classes maybe a portion of these people
can become
green meaning safe to follow over time
we're real
rule out cancer in that group and the
converse may be true some proportion of
these people
may be higher risk and we bring them in
and we
offer a biopsy because they are more
likely to be malignant
so these reclassification of the
intermediate group
from the yellow to a low-risk group in
grain or high-risk group in red
is the goal of this effort
we are trying to deal with these tough
nodules
so would eventually a bowel marker help
us here
is the question and we can talk briefly
about biomarkers and what
they need to show well biomarkers are
basically
a reflection of whether what we're
dealing with
may be either cancer or no cancer well
we have to make sure that we have an
assay that's accurate
and that's valid that it has been tested
in
other population that it causes a large
number of
of cancer to be diagnosed early and if
you diagnose it earlier
instead of diagnosing most people stage
three or four
you shift it to diagnosing stage one
where the diet
the prognosis is a lot better you can
survive
and up to 70 or 80 of people with stage
one lung cancer now survive five years
now we want to reduce the number of
false positive and we want
to make sure that whatever biomarker
brings in
uh eventually makes a big difference in
terms of it adds value to what
the current standard of managing
managements are
they're not the strategy the biomarker
that is an imaging or a blood biomarker
must be cost effective and eventually
save lives that's the ultimate goal
but i think that a reasonable target is
to demonstrate that we are
adding value to the current management
this is where we want biomarkers to be
so in collaboration with a group in the
united
kingdom we started looking at
imaging biomarkers and what we did is we
grabbed a large number of chess cts like
the one i showed you earlier
we had a total of 15 000
uh benign lung nodules from different
individuals
and about 932 cancer
and that population comes from the
natural lung screening trial
so we identified so many nodules and
from
all these images we developed an
artificial intelligence
strategy to identify
what is cancer from what is benign and
then we decided that once we have our
artificial intelligence model we're
going to validate it
we're going to validate in three
different ways one within the same
trial the national lung screening trial
and then in two independent courts one
from the
u.s and one from the uk and here is what
we found
we grouped that population we had to
deal with a large population
from the national lung screening trial
over 15 000 nodules
vanderbilt we had 116 and oxford 463
and then we tested our artificial
intelligence
model here in the nlst and validating
these
different groups there are different
characteristics there's too many numbers
on this slide ignore it
but this is to tell you that we
basically trained in
one cohort and validated in two
independent cores
so how does this artificial intelligence
model works it's a prediction and
machine
learning method we call it lung cancer
predictor
convolutional neural network the neural
network is basically
taking a bunch of images like you see in
the ace part of the slide
and bringing them to a computer to have
them recognize
what is a cancer and what is a benign
nodule
and then we train the classifier to at
the end
gives us an answer as to whether the
image we have in front of us is likely
to be cancerous or not and give us a
percentage of
likelihood score of cancer let's say 75
chance that this is a cancer this is how
we train it in b
you see that in the training data set we
provide the
the artificial intelligence model
with three nodules two that are benign
one that's malignant and then
we give them a large number of nodules
and the better
uh the module the the model gets a lot
better with the large number of nodules
so we end up with over 15 000 nodules
and train the model
if the model gets the answer wrong we
retrain the model we'll refine the model
there's an iterative aspect to this
training procedure and at the end we
give
the model unknown nodules and we ask
them tell us what it is
and then we see in what percentage of
the time we are accurate at determining
if this is a cancer
and this is a benign one so here
um i wanted to show you a little video
that
illustrates how we eventually
perform this analysis based on
the images that are selected on our
imaging record
we can actually download directly the
images
and you'll see that we screen through
the images really quickly there is a
nodule in the right upper lobe
we're going to identify and select that
nodule in the right upper lobe find its
center
click on the very center of the nodule
itself
and try to draw a sphere around it
now the nodule is going to be segmented
and we're going to ask a software to
give us a probability
of cancer and here we are the
probability of cancer in this particular
nodule
is 98 very high risk for cancer
now we did this in the national lung
screening trial data set
and what we showed is that compared to a
clinical model
as to uh whether this is malignant or
not
the uh the artificial intelligence
tool gives us better discrimination
these are called
uh receiver operating operative
characteristic curves
and you see that the pin curve is
better because it's more to the left and
to the top part of the slide
and it gives an accuracy that goes from
85 percent to 92 percent
these seven percent improvement in
accuracy don't seem like a large number
but it's a tremendous improvement now if
we try to validate this in the
vanderbilt cohort
or in the oxford cohort every time
we beat the clinical prediction alone
and the
clinical prediction really include the
age the history of smoking
the history of cancer in the past how
big the nodule is
and whether his shape is regular or
irregular
so our artificial intelligence model is
quite better and actually it allows us
to reclassify about a third of the
nodules
back to this figure here if you see
these
intermediate risk nodule in yellow
we were able to reclassify about a third
of them into a lower risk group a high
risk group
what does that do well it actually
um decreases the number of
in not necessary procedures so
unnecessary procedures we do
and then also decrease the time to
diagnosis because we're
better and faster identifying the bad
guys
when we rule in disease
so this is the uh the state of the art
now
of this biomarker which is an imaging
biomarker
so where do we want to go there we we
have demonstrated that
we have discovered a good model we have
validated analytically and in three
different cohorts
now we want to do a clinical utility
study and that clinical utility study
will tell you
and me whether this is gonna help
patients get their diagnose
done earlier and with fewer procedures
and whether eventually this may save
lives
so we need to get to a
proposal of a clinical trial
and to bring patients and
biomarkers onto a train and the idea
that we are
we are riding this train with our lung
nodules
and we want some bowel markers to be
tested to see whether
we are accurate and clinically useful
we're going to test a bunch of
biomarkers on the train we're going to
take some on it
and we're going to let some of these
biomarkers that are not useful
leave the train and we'll arrive at
destination hopefully with a great
proposal
so how do we propose to do this in a
randomized fashion
what does it mean if you are let's say
60 years old
and you present with a lung nodule
that's in this intermediate risk
we're not totally sure whether it's
benign or not we would randomize you
into two groups a group that has
just a standard of care and we follow
you over time that's our control group
or an intervention group and the
intervention group here
will offer some type of biomarker it
could be a clinical model
a blood viral marker or our imaging
biomarker
and our imaging biomarker will be
applied directly to the chest ct that
you have
that you come to your doctor with we
look at the imaging
we run our artificial intelligence tool
and the tool tells us that no in fact
you're not in the intermediate risk
you are much lower risk you're in the
low risk group
and we can follow you you follow you
safely
with just a chest ct that would be quite
reassuring
if the bowel marker our imaging lung
um artificial intelligence
model tells us no your nigel is actually
pretty high risk
we rather you get a biopsy we'll follow
these
strategies get the biopsy that your
doctors decide
on getting and eventually look at the
end point and in this trial within two
years we'll know whether
we're able to improve the diagnostic
accuracy decrease the number the time it
took us to
get the diagnosis and reduce the number
of invasive procedures
so this is the goal of where we want to
take these
candidate biomarkers now the biomarkers
can be
found in the blood like a protein or a
dna testing or a genomic test
in the circulation of your blood
and we can test these biomarkers
following the same
clinical trial strategy here and
reclassify your risk
based on the results of the biomarker
into low or high-risk group
and then we will be able to test the
difference between our intervention
strategy versus the control strategy
well with this um i want to finish by
telling you that ultimately
we want biomarkers into the clinical
arena
they need to be non-invasive we need to
demonstrate that we improve the
management
by showing fuel morbidity and
decreasing the number of expensive
procedures
we want to improve the decision making
we watch and wait or we biopsy and we
want to make sure that we have the right
population that we're focusing on
and we want to test the technology that
the same time is quite
sensitive and that is specific as well
tells us that this nigel is a cancer we
better not make a mistake
and take you to surgery for the wrong
reason
to answer these questions of clinical
utility we need
a clinical trial and this is what i'm
currently working on with a number of
collaborators
so with this i want to conclude and i
think i told you that the biomarkers
have different layers of evidence
in my opinion those that are valuable
are better than the standard of care
which i showed you with this artificial
intelligence
tool the diagnostic biomarkers
should not have harm and it should be
offered to patients in the shared
decision making we need to discuss
the accuracy and the performance of the
biomarkers
and accept some or some uncertainty of
any
new biomarker that we bring into a
clinical study
patients must be willing to participate
into this
and i think when we want to scale up
this type of testing
we want to partner with the industry
because they are
very good at eventually bringing some of
these candidate biomarkers to the clean
call
bedside and have those eventually
approved by the fda so with this i want
to
tell you that we need randomized
clinical trials
also in the diagnostic setting we want
to work with
people with clinical expertise and we
want to make sure that the patients
are involved in the design of these
studies and then we're honoring their
wishes
so in my final slide here is to say that
we talked about how do we personalize
the risk
we need an informed consent we want to
keep it simple
we want to work with statistical models
that are very necessary to help us
assess
the strength and robustness of our
biomarkers
we need to look at the continuous risk
factors
and risk prediction models to eventually
find a solution
to address the shortcomings of our
current evaluation of lung nodules
i want to thank all the patients who are
participating in the studies that i've
presented here
and a large number of collaborators
without which i could not do this work
and these involve people who are
research coordinator
biostatisticians clinicians
imagers of course people expert in
biomarkers
uh biorepository chemistry
epidemiology and and screening in
general
so i want to thank the funding support
and my
collaborators and you all for listening
to me today
and hopefully i've provided you with
some good hopes
that not only lung cancer is a
big cancer mortality problem
but we are trying to tackle it with new
early detection methods
and in these detection methods chest ct
screening
seems to be remarkably efficient we want
to
keep improving its efficacy by bringing
biomarkers to non-invasively
diagnose the disease early and bring it
to a treatment
so with this i want to thank everybody
and
wish you a very good day i'd be happy to
take any questions
at this point and back to you kristen
thank you pierre for that outstanding
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of our webinar
now as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions via the q
a box okay pierre first question
is there any strategy for early
detection among
smokers so among smokers the best
strategy
is to convince them to quit smoking
that sounds a little facetious but it's
the truth
and it could be the priority number one
two and three
once the people are high risk meaning
that
over the age of 55 they've smoked for
about
30 years a pack a day or so and that
they quit less than 15 years
they should undergo lung cancer chest ct
screening
and this is not a one-time test this is
a process
a surveillance program over time over
long periods of time until there's no
need for screening anymore
so yes there is a strategy for smokers
now for non-smokers that's a different
uh
problem we currently do not have
a good strategy for early detection of
lung cancer among
non-smokers and those people represent
about
10 15 of the population it's a larger
population
in southeast asia where up to 30 percent
of the people diagnosed with lung cancer
are never smokers
it's a very important problem to tackle
and we need to do a lot more research in
that space
thank you now what's the biggest
challenge in developing
biomarkers for lung cancer
the biggest challenge to develop
biomarkers
in my opinion is designing the studies
early on right
and choosing the population that you
want to bring your biomarker
in judiciously let me give you an
example
if you want to find a biomarker for
early detection of lung cancer
i would not start looking for biomarkers
in people with very advanced stage
disease
who don't undergo screening i would try
to
design studies to find the biomarker
in the population that you intend to
screen
that's very important the second is that
you need to have
a very sensitive method because
chest ct screening is actually pretty
sensitive to fine
nodules but when we find nodules we know
that the disease has been there for
months
so ultimately you want to be exquisitely
sensitive
and find the disease very early but the
problem when you're very sensitive
is that you may find some false positive
you may be mistakenly taking a nodule
for a cancer when in fact it's a small
infection
so that brings me to specificity which
means that
when the disease when the nodule is
called the cancer it must be a cancer
okay so and that
if i call it negative it's not a cancer
i'd better be
for sure that this is not a cancer so
this specificity is very important these
two metrics are very
important and another important part is
to bring the
biomarkers to clinical utility
meaning that it's not good enough to
have a good marker that discriminate one
from the other it has to be better than
the standard of care
and most biomarkers fail at that level
because to be standard of care is hard
it's like athletes when you get good in
athletics
and you know you know you could be a
wonderful
basketball player but to make uh the
state warriors
team you need to be at the very best and
few are elected in that zone so that's
where we want to be thank you for that
answer
and what does clinical utility mean
well clinical utility um means something
different from different people in
general
but if i ask you what it means you
probably tell me well something that'd
be good for me
and that's the right answer in medicine
and in biomarkers research
clinical utility has different layers
one could think that if i
manage to diagnose a lung cancer at an
earlier stage
it may be clinically useful but
if that bowel marker gets me an earlier
stage without being better from what
we're already doing
it's not good enough so here the
benchmark is not big enough
what's the next benchmark the benchmark
would say okay it's better than
standard of care well that would be
terrific already people start
commercializing the biomarker
but it may not be good enough because it
may then may not demonstrate that we're
actually saving lives
ultimately we want to save lives
well people say well maybe that's too
high of a bar
and you may want to lower the bar a
little bit and say well at least if
we're saving money
in managing learning modules you would
reach a reasonable
clinical utility benchmark and so
it depends on who you're talking to it's
a very difficult uh
concept clinical utility has many many
different layers and many different
uh meaning to different people but to
most patients
is pretty simple it's whether this is
going to help me
in managing the disease better than
everything else that's out there at the
moment
and here we have time for one more
question i'd like to go with this last
one where would you think
biomarkers fall in the future in
comparison to imaging
well i'm i'm pretty sure that biomarkers
have a role
now the technologies are getting better
and better we're getting
more sensitive at detecting
very very subtle differences between
groups
we are getting very very good at
detecting minute traces of abnormal
molecules in our blood it's true for
proteins
is true for transcripts
rna is true for dna it's true for
methylated dna or marked on the dna
it's true for metabolites that we can
detect in the blood
i think the technology keeps improving
and will bring
very early weakness of that
disease that's circulating somewhere now
the challenge that
the biomarkers again need to
add complementary information to what we
already know
and um in many diseases
we see that biomarkers are growing in
their
importance you see this in
cardiovascular medicine
in diabetes management in the management
of
anti-autoimmune diseases
you see this in the management of many
many diseases biomarkers are coming to
the forefront
because they're molecular and they are
beyond the macroscope
they're beyond what traditional medicine
can do
yet they have a tough mark and it's to
show added value to the current
standards
and this is the biggest challenge we
have in biomarkers research i have no
doubt that
some type of non-invasive biomarkers is
going to help us
diagnose lung cancer in a non-invasive
way and will add value to imaging
and by the way imaging is improving
every day too
so we have better resolution scanners
multiple detectors
a very small voxel density we're going
to get artificial
intelligence models better than the one
i showed you and we're going to be not
just looking at the nodule we're going
to look at the entire patient
and maybe it is that the emphysema
that's associated with the nodule that's
going to give us even more information
so we have a lot more study to be done
in the biomarkers field biomarkers that
are either
molecular based or imaging based
so there's a lot of hope for the future
and the the future is
coming very quickly it's assumed that
we'll see these differences
that it is dr macian and thank you so
much for this excellent presentation
and very detailed q a session i also
want to thank our audience for
their outstanding questions we hope that
you have found today's presentation to
be informative and insightful
today's presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing
also don't miss out on the other
valuable presentations on our agenda
just visit that agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and dr museum thank you and for
thank you again for your time until next
time everyone
have a great day bye-bye bye-bye it was
my pleasure thank you
thank you